hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong i am mark ellis
who almost went
to a dodger game last night thanks to
our incredible engineer brian perez i
said no
i said no couldn't do it had stand-up
going on but what what a sweet gentleman
to invite me uh jacqueline coley is also
the host of this show rotten tomatoes
jacqueline last time we could have seen
you at a professional sporting event was
when
the last time you would have seen me at
a professional sporting event yeah maybe
a mavs game
oh no texas rangers texas rangers
opening day
2020. okay okay no 2019 before the panda
that works right yeah i like a i like a
good baseball game but everybody missed
a great moment a few weeks ago in the
nba finals when the the warriors hit a
big three and then they pandered the
crowd and there's this poor guy this guy
and i think it's his wife and they're
celebrating but then he goes to high
five his wife with both hands he went in
with both hands and the wife had turned
away and so he was left hanging not just
of high five hanging but a high ten
hanging and it kind of made the rounds
on the sports talk shows the next day
like how do you patch things up as a
couple going to sports games as couples
it's a it's it that you could get on
kiss cam there's a lot of risk is all
i'm saying so did she turn away from him
on purpose or was it just like she
happened to turn away she happened to
turn away but it didn't look good it
didn't look good for the relationship is
all i'm gonna say it's like dude i used
you to get these tickets and now i'm
just gonna see my options so it didn't
look
yeah i don't know where they are now now
that the nba finals has passed but what
is ongoing and what seems to probably be
occurring for the next few decades at
the very least is the mcu that stands
for marvel cinematic universe kids and
now they're not just movies they're
streaming tv shows doing baffo business
if not box office because you can catch
all these shows that debuted with juan
division i remember back at d23 the big
disney convention where they unleash all
their new exciting products and what's
coming out in years to come they said
wanda vision and they gave the pitch and
it's like what the hell is this thing
about it was a left turn for sure but it
ended up paying off and then ever since
we've gotten your hawkeye show you got
loki you got moon knight and you got
falcon of the winter soldier and now we
just had miss marvel do an impressive
run she-hulk coming out in august on
disney plus so we're gonna be talking
about all of these streaming shows
that have completed as of this recording
and so i'm going to run down what the
tomato meter says about these programs
and then we have a very special guest
with us who's going to debate whether
rotten tomatoes got this order right or
wrong
these are all really fresh they're
really really surprisingly so so at
number one it's a tie between loki and
hawkeye both of whom are 92 percent
certified fresh so we're gonna make loki
number one because it's got more reviews
than hawkeye loki's one hawkeyes 1a both
at 92 percent and then you have one
division falling off a cliff all the way
down to 91 percent certified
so that's pretty impressive moon knight
is in the third position or fourth
depending on how you want to rate it at
86 certified fresh and then bring up the
rear as of right now is the falcon and
the winter soldier at 83 percent
certified fresh so jaclyn we're dealing
with a lot of a's and b's these shows
can probably get into an ivy league
school at least like dartmouth or brown
right yes they absolutely can and i
don't believe that these are actually by
our adjusted score so this is just this
is just i think we sort of decided but
definitely ranked but just want to
clarify on people these are not based on
our rotten tomatoes adjusted ranking
score but hey man i think it's a fairly
accurate representation of the way
critics felt about it i think the fans
might disagree with some of these
rankings but i'm digging it that's what
we're here to talk about tim ryan might
have some uh updated tomato meter
figures for us but in the meantime it is
a privilege to welcome i can't believe
it's we've almost done 100 of these
things it's the very first time that our
good buddy matt ramos aka soups is
joining us an entertainment journalist a
host you know him from his incredible
youtube channel social media presence
and now soups is joining the show maddie
it it is so good to to see and talk to
you just before i ask you this this
question about rotten tomatoes being
wrong or being right about the order of
these mcu shows what does it do for you
a lifelong comic book fan seeing these
stuff on the big screen but now also
having access to these storytelling on
the small screen how exciting is it to
be you having all these shows coming out
one after another
i mean mark you kind of referenced this
earlier we were both in that room in d23
when marvel had their disney plus panel
and kevin feige walked out on stage and
he brought out the cast of juan division
loki falcon under the winter soldier and
then went on to announce miss marvel
she-hulk moon night
the energy in that building was
electrifying and rightfully so because
as great as the mcu movies are now
disney plus has given us the opportunity
to enjoy this amazing content on a
weekly basis like it's crazy to me that
right now we are in the we are admits
between obi-wan kenobi and ms marvel
coming out on the same day like it's
just it's so much all at once but that's
i guess that's the opportunity that
disney plus has provided us and it just
gives us more content to enjoy and to
see characters like kamala khan to see
characters like moon knight brought to
life in the mcu through these shows it's
been pretty awesome to see
it's almost too much to watch and then
you wake up and you check on twitter and
nope everybody's watched it and they're
already talking about it so you better
get on board with those spoilers and so
i'm going to give you that that rundown
one more time because loki and hawkeye
tied at one wand one division right
behind it moon knight right behind that
and then the falcon in the winter
soldier is rotten tomatoes wrong about
just that ranking of the mcu shows for
your personal taste soups how different
would yours be or is rotten tomatoes
right
i could definitely understand this
ranking and i'm glad that all of these
shows are are rated they have a fresh
rating you know they're all certified
fresh and that's and that's a that's a
great thing because i think every single
one of these shows is good and none of
them are
no one can define any of these shows
that's bad however there is some major
disrespect on this list to moon knight i
think moon knight is the best marvel
disney plus series
and right under moon knight i have loki
which is at the top of this list and i
actually have hawkeye at the bottom of
my list so
i have moonlight at the top hawk at the
bottom and you know right here we have
falcon in the winter soldier certified
at 83
certified fresh
and i i have a problem with that because
i i do think
that the falcon of the winter soldier is
the most underrated marvel disney plush
show by far i think it has aged pretty
well it's very rewatchable and i think
it's about time we give the [ __ ] in
the winter soldier it's flowers because
that was a good show and i think it's
pretty underrated okay i mean it might
be a at least a like fest here jaclyn
because i don't think we're going to
bring a lot of hate for any of these
shows necessarily i also really like
what if but if you're looking at this do
you think ron tomatoes is wrong about
the rating of these shows
a little bit um juan division is just an
exceptional piece of television and i'm
sorry it should be number one all the
way through it's not even a question of
whether it's a good superhero show it's
a great piece of television that's why
it was nominated for an emmy and so was
elizabeth olsen but oh sorry i believe
actually elizabeth olsen got snubbed and
it was paul bettany don't don't don't uh
don't hit me up on that i'm a film
someone in the couple got nominated one
of them didn't anyway the whole point
being is
i think that one is just incredible it
you know definitely was a show that
people loved and i don't think people
realized just the immense tasks that it
had to do being as it wasn't even
supposed to be the first one out of the
gate and it managed to still be in my
opinion the best so i would definitely
put that higher i do think loki would
definitely be probably my number two and
then it's a tie for third
pick em they can do a battle royale as i
like to say i'm easy to rank the top
after that they all kind of wash
together in a right mood i might say
moon knight in the right mood i might
say falcon in the winter soldier or
hawkeye it just depends yeah i i think
ron tomatoes is kind of right and kind
of very wrong here because i actually
have loki as my least favorite there's
things i can enjoy about it for sure but
i have loki uh at that bottom position
but i do have hawkeye at the top i just
maybe it's when i came across hawkeye i
just enjoyed that adventure and maybe i
liked hawkeye because i just felt like i
could just put it on and watch it and i
didn't have to digest too much of the
the connective tissue linking stories in
the mcu but i also
wanted to give a shout out to what if
and even go back to agents of shield
just because these are also technically
you know shows that came out under the
banner of at least marvel television but
we're just ranking our face for mcu tv
shows that have been completed as of
this recording just so everyone knows
and doesn't yell at us about where's
miss marble where's she-hulk we're gonna
get to him eventually i promise you but
right now where we are is our favorite
segment because we take a break from
talking and we turn it over to our
expert review curation manager here at
rotten tomatoes tim ryan who is going to
tell us what the critics were and i
guess are saying about these mcu tv
shows timmy take it away
[Music]
we could spend all day talking about
marvel television series so right off
the bat apologies to lou ferrigno agents
of shield daredevil and my faves luke
cage and jessica jones among many others
this quick tomato meter rundown is going
to focus exclusively on the mcu's phase
4 tv series the too long didn't read
version is each of them are certified
fresh and each has an audience score
that's separated from the critic score
by a single digit let's do this one
division is certified fresh at 91 on the
tomato meter and it has an 88 audience
score falcon in the winter soldier is
certified fresh at a 3 percent and it
has an 84 audience score loki is
certified fresh at 92 and has a 91
audience score
what if is certified fresh at 94 and has
a 94 audience score and just like loki
hawkeye is also certified fresh at 92
and also has a 91 audience score and
finally moon knight is certified fresh
at 86 and has a 92 audience score given
that we're talking about six different
shows it's impossible to get an overall
flavor of the critical consensus from a
couple reviews but here goes anyway in a
fresh review for loki josh wilding of
comicbookmovie.com writes nothing can
prepare you for loki a mind-bending dive
into the marvel multiverse that takes
everything you thought you knew about
the mcu and turns it on its head for one
of the most ambitious craziest stories
marvel studios has ever told
however in a rotten review of moon
knight chris wasser of ireland's sunday
independent wrote the rickety action
sequences paired with questionable cgi
drippy horror terrible jokes a shoddily
assembled mystery and one too many
rounds of over-the-top violence combined
to make moon knight an unfortunate dud
on the marvel roster so those are the
phase four mcu series let's kick it back
to jacqueline and mark two people who
perpetually ask themselves what are we
looking at here is it an alternate
reality some cockamamie social
experiment the answer is it's a podcast
back to you folks it certainly is a
podcast or at least that's the goal each
and every week and we strive to get as
close to that as possible so let's shift
gears right into i guess for this week
tv talk
[Music]
all right soups i mean we heard the
highs and the lows as far as the the
critics consensus and some of the
critical response to these mcu tv shows
before we get into specifics about why a
show is your favorite or least favorite
i have a question that's very general
you can take it any way you want to
is there a world in which you actually
prefer watching a couple of these tv
shows to the movies themselves or do you
hold the movies as okay those are the
ones that i love and then it's nice to
have these supplemental episodes in
between movie releases yeah for sure i
still think that the now that we have
the disney plus shows to keep us busy
for the majority of the year i actually
think it's elevated our appreciation for
the movies because now when we get to
the movies you know i just think there
are the movies that we've gotten in
facebook have been on a much bigger
scale and
i
i don't know i think yeah i i do think
that the show's the fact that now we
have the majority of of the year
consuming these shows it's elevated the
movies because i do think
the movies are just more enjoyable than
the shows not to say that the shows
aren't enjoyable because they they are
but
i i do find them the movie i do still
find the movies more enjoyable than the
shows yeah jacqueline do you get up for
the for the tv shows as much as the
movies or do you fee i mean i think i'm
kind of on matt's wavelength where it's
like
the movies just feel like such an event
where it's it's like the the song in
annie where you're like singing about
going to the movies because you're that
excited as opposed to like like in annie
there's never a song like let's all sit
down on the couch and stream a show
that's how i feel how about you
jacqueline yeah i mean look i
i may be prescribed to the more
cinephile thing of like i feel there's a
bit of permanence to seeing a movie in
the movie theater you develop memories
around them because you actually had to
like buy the ticket go to the theater
probably bring someone with you so
they're attached to your viewing of it
um whereas if you're watching it at home
they can all kind of run together and i
do think it's telling that i love all of
these shows and i've seen
at least more than half of each of them
i've not seen all of them all the way
through and i think that's because yeah
i but i've seen every single marvel
movie since iron man so and i've seen
every single one of them in a theater i
think that that right there is the the
real dichotomy of it in and that lack of
i would say tangibility to it because i
remember falcon in the winter soldier i
did q and a's for it i talked to the
cast and the filmmakers but if you asked
me to walk down that plot point by point
bullet pipe bullet it would take me a
little bit but if you ask me to give you
the plot of doctor strange i can give it
to you tomorrow
like i can give it to you right now you
know what i mean
it's it's just like
it doesn't
stay with you as long i i do like that
we have time to get our hands dirty into
a story mat with the the multiple
episodes the longer running time so if
you're looking at your favorite one of
these phase four mcu shows
why is that one your favorite what what
about it makes it stand above the rest
for me moon knight has been my favorite
marvel disney plush shows and there's
multiple reasons first off i think oscar
isaac is just a larger than life actor
and he's just had such a great run in
2022 2021 and now that he's coming over
into the mcu like this was a great debut
for him to enter the mcu he just gave a
phenomenal performance playing multiple
characters got us to care about steven
as like
almost like we stephen was like our
little child and we got to see him grow
up throughout the series and then we
also had mark and now by the end of the
series spoilers we have jake lockley who
the series teed up very very nicely so i
also think a huge part of these shows is
is the way they stick the landing the
way they end and i think there was a lot
of worry amongst a lot of people after
moon episode 5 because it might not have
particularly set up the final episode to
to
be i guess satisfying but that final
episode was very satisfying and there
were a lot of payoffs we had freaking
cgi egyptian gods fighting each other
stephen was kicking ass as mr knight i
absolutely loved the finale of this show
and again it also gave us that jake
lockley payoff which a lot of us
had been wanting but i think at the core
of why i believe muna is the best disney
plush show
is because
all of the disney plush shows that we
got previous to moon knight the main
protagonist
was a side character that wasn't big
enough to have their own movie wanda
after one division now she's big enough
to have her own movie
loki
he i don't think loki was a character
that was big enough to have his own film
oh disagree sorry
i'm like i'm gonna put some shade on you
on that one sorry no sir he could have
had a movie he could have a movie i
don't think so i don't think hawkeye was
big enough to have had his own movie but
i think moonlight is a character that
you look at and you think man he should
probably have a movie over a disney plus
series because moonai is that big of a
character but instead we got a moonlight
disney plus series and it was a great
experience and i thought it was a great
way to introduce the character into the
mcu so i that's why i have mooned at my
number one i'll i'll meet y'all halfway
japan because i feel like loki is a big
enough character to have his own movie
but i feel like the story that you're
telling in this loki tv show no way
you're pulling that off in in one movie
which is why i think a lot of folks
appreciate particularly that show and
the freedom that the streaming
format afforded it is to take your time
with bending the literal time and the
universe real quickly to touch up on
moon night though
i feel like the sense of humor in moon
knight doesn't get enough run because i
do think that there's a lot of good it's
not overt jokes in there it's more like
a you're just following along this poor
bastard mark
and you know everything that that his
sort of job entails and and he's living
these
he's got to pull off this sort of double
duty and seeing that play out and i also
give a shout out to uh may kawamawai
who's just awesome
uh as layla and how much more herster
her story unfolds and and then obviously
seeing ethan hawk as as arthur harrow i
i think that that show brought a
different element to the mcu but i do
want to jump onto this loki thing now
because
jacqueline the thing about the loki show
to me is that you know how i feel about
multiverses you know how i feel about
time bending i get that loki
opens up and it just blows every
everything in the mcu out of the water i
don't want that i at some point i need
you to
establish what the universe is what the
limits are and then that's the sandbox
we have to play in and it seems like
with loki it's just an excuse to
infinitely move the goal post so that we
can cram as much stuff into the mcu as
possible and i just it's too much for my
pee brain to comprehend
um
is it mark yeah you're weird
it's so weird i feel like mark pulse
multiverse is just fully embracing his
like
guys at the top of the muppets like uh
what are their names uh battler and
waldorf and yes yeah like you are very
that now because the multiverse i really
feel you were like
did we have to
like i
you know soups i'm already trying to
placate the mcu with and i love the
guardians movies and i love thor being
on asgard so it's like look we're
allowing for different planets and
universes to be in this one
sort of marvel cinematic umbrella but
now we got now we're bending time too
and we've controlled all this i i hate
knowing that there were people that knew
how everything played out in endgame but
like before we that just bothers me and
i can't get over it am i maybe i am just
a simple tenor maybe i'm just a maybe i
just turned into a curmudgeon i i don't
know but i i cannot get behind loki as
an air the performances are great great
seeing tom hiddleston great seeing on
wilson can't get behind that story
though actually i i really enjoyed
looking story again i think a lot my for
me personally my enjoyment of a lot of
these disney plush shows is the journey
that they take us on and the way they
stick the landing of that journey and
with with all of the theories going on
on us potentially seeing kang in the
show
using jonathan majors in that finale was
awesome and he completely stole that
episode and i think the loki show
because this was a show that was
designed to have multiple seasons unlike
the other disney plus shows i think it
was written and they told the story a
certain way for a reason you know this
show was our introduction to variance to
essentially like the multiverse being
born in a way by the end with loki
killing he who or with sylvia killing
here who remains and then us seeing
richard e grants the other loki's
alligator loki like the the
like there was so much to enjoy with
this series and i think the the one of
the best parts about it is that it did
such a great job at building the world
and introducing us to this lore
going into spider-man knowing home going
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness i think that's the thing for
me jacqueline is that the multiverse and
then knowing that there's these keepers
of time it makes everything that i've
experienced in the movies feel a little
less important and dramatic knowing that
we kind of already knew this is the way
it was going to go and so for whatever
reason i feel like you know i still have
those moments in the theater where i was
lucky enough to be at the premiere of
endgame and it was like stadium seating
at the la convention center and you had
the the air conditioning blowing on you
like you were outside at soldier field
in the summer
but it just it's like oh they already
knew this was going to happen yeah i
don't know it just kind of dulls the
impact for me
i i was there also at the eleven
convention center because the thing
about end game you could just tell that
marvel was like no we doing it all we're
not holding anything back star wars put
a death put the millennium falcon on
hollywood well we're gonna take up a
convention center kids let's go
uh yeah no there is a certain aspect and
i will give you this mark once you did
that big spectacle there's a certain
aspect of the mcu that has to go and get
smaller like they did with iron man for
a while for them to get to another bit
of spectacle so
i think the interesting thing with the
multiverse and the thing i hope you will
just think about when you start to get
you that communist rising in you like
when you feel the fury coming like just
take this moment of centering and own
this emotion
like i'm let me do a little gentle
parenting here
this is the only way that we can really
go because if they don't make it weird
and small
this is gonna be so
unwieldy soon that we can't deal with it
like this chaos that you hate right now
and the tension headache that it's
giving you is so that you can still
enjoy these films in 10 years because
they really do need something like that
to fix the fact that they've made it
like like basically once you got to
endgame they hadn't written anything
after that and so they put this
multiverse device out there to sort of
create a parachute after they had
already jumped out of the plane and so
we're currently in the terrifying
moments of riding the parachute
before we splat on the ground and so
like i feel your comedy moment in this
but just understand
if they didn't throw us out of the plane
with this weird little
multiverse magic key we would have just
been sitting up there with end game and
trying to chase that high like a drug
addict and we know that doesn't work
okay thanks for putting it that way now
i feel like tom cruise in the mummy
who's screaming like when the plane is
going down i'm just looking for the last
parachute to pull i will say though
if nothing else stuff like loki and even
one division to a degree i i so
appreciated wanda vision for having the
bold stroke of genius to take that left
turn and and to
kind of subvert expectations as to what
you could get in a you know comic book
tv show i thought it was brilliant in
that regard but i also really like
hawkeye and that hawkeye's my favorite
matt simply
because it is just that smaller story
where we just have this little thing and
there's a superhero kind of finding
their wings with haley steinfeld's
character and i like the team up i like
that christmas feel to it and we did get
some fun though i mean we got to see you
know kingpin pop in and so there's a lot
of cool stuff in hawkeye and i i like
the the sense of humor was more on the
nose there so hawkeye i think was more
right up my alley as somebody who loves
buddy action flicks but you said that i
think that might be your least favorite
yeah hawkeye is my least favorite but
like you said like i just i agree with
everything you just said like seeing
hawkeye kind of deal with the ptsd and
fallout of endgame and his time as ronan
that was awesome to see and i thought
that did a great job developing clint's
character than getting hayley steinfeld
kate bishop was so awesome and so
lovable in that show and i cannot wait
to see
what else they have in store for kate
bishop because she was so awesome in the
show and
that
kind of buddy cop style of storytelling
with the hawkeye show set in christmas
with hawkeye trying to finish this all
up so like i think again he can get back
home to his family for christmas then we
also got vincent d'onofrio as kingpin
there was a lot to enjoy that hawkeye
series for me where the series kind of i
guess dipped is i just think in the
finale like there was such a build up to
kingpin and i think having
having known kingpin to be what he is in
the netflix daredevil show compared to
what he was in the hawkeye finale i just
think there's a discrepancy there and i
i just i didn't like the way they
portrayed kingpin in that finale but i'm
still very excited for that daredevil
disney plus series that's on the horizon
i'm very excited for echo and i think
echo is another great part of the series
that not many people talk about seeing
her introduction because she's gonna
have her own disney plus series um
yelena yeah elena was awesome in this so
yeah hawkeye hawkeye was definitely a
very enjoyable disney plus series but
for me i just enjoyed the other ones
more than this one i think it does prove
just how much of maybe a purist or a
mainstream the consumer i am of this
stuff jacqueline is because i think that
the the tv shows best service can be
introduced a new character that will one
day get the big screen treatment like a
kate bishop haley steinfeld's character
where did jacqueline coley stand on
hawkeye i just okay i don't want to say
this because i love haley i really do
love haley and the series had a lot
going with it but hawkeye very much felt
like a series that kept trying to
apologize for existing
and i didn't like that like it kept
feeling like yeah we know you don't
really want to spend your time with this
character but we promise he's worth it
you know what i mean like it seemed like
it was too
in on that joke like we know he's not
famous enough to get his own movie just
let him have a tv show yeah exactly
honestly to me kind of did a disservice
like the thing with hawkeye is they kind
of did the thing they had to do with gal
gadot in the first wonder woman this
character's cringe factor is so high you
just have to lean into it otherwise
people aren't going to believe the
premise which i do think is correct you
have to lean into the fact that he just
has a bow and arrow and he's you know
literally running around with gods but i
just feel like they didn't move away
from that enough to be like he was still
cool killer ronan dude like let's like
own that this dude has some edge to him
and like
like he it's almost like they made
hawkeye different things in these movies
and in the show they just wanted to keep
him the guy on the farm
in
civil war i think he wants to be the guy
on the farm and so i i think he's not
though he's not though and he's a much
more interesting character when you
realize that he was the guy that would
have murked a bunch of people because of
the fact that he was so obsessed about
being in the farm that is the cockeye
character that i would like to see a
show about and they just ran away from
it in every way yeah maybe it is just
the family angle that it took place at
christmas they're like okay
let's have kingpin but not like that
kingpin and let's have hawkeye but let's
just have it like a nicer gentler maybe
i'm becoming a family man right before
everyone's eyes mark ellis rated pg in
theaters this christmas jacqueline you
said that you loved wanda vision that
you feel like one division is worthy of
the awards that it has won it is great
television what is the jaclyn coley
sales pitch for why wanda vision should
be the best show in the mcu
let me borrow a word that if you are
careful on the internet you can find a
long-running clip of her saying it over
and over again and i am going to quote
the late great jamie lee curt oh not the
late great the very great and currently
still living jamie lee curtis come on
laurie strode lori strode
trauma
it's trauma ladies and gentlemen it is
the t word it is the thing that i live
for give me a broken woman on the edge
of destruction and looking to destroy
the world that broke her and i am in
from billy wilder in the apartment to
bridgette jones everywhere in a shaper
phone give me broken women i love broken
women i love watching them put
themselves back together and i like
watching them be as messy as possible
meredith gray early seasons i'm talking
to you so yeah it's the trauma it's the
fact that that marvel really for once
took what happens to these people not
these superheroes these people and what
does that do to these people who have
the trauma of everyone else but the
superpowers of gods and where does that
lead and what scary things do they have
to deal with within their own mind that
are just as terrifying and bizarre as
the realistic things and the best part
of that was is you didn't even realize
that was what you were watching until
like chapter seven
like this was another just great bait
and switch is that we were literally
watching the longest grief march in the
history of television and you didn't
clock it until the movie the show was
halfway over because it was just coded
in this three camera sitcom setup and
then also like this leave it to beaver
kind of feel but then you have what i
think that these streaming shows do best
matt is
they are able to take a feeling a line
of thought from one of the movies and
really extrapolate it and so when we
talk about the ptsd that a lot of these
superheroes would probably feel and we
see it in shows that can be a little
more how should i say visceral about it
with like the boys you know but with
with wanda vision it reminded me of that
wine in iron man 3 when tony and rody
are bonding as bros do at hooters and
they're having that conversation and he
said and tony says nothing's been the
same since new york and he's kind of
hinting that he's having some real
issues mentally emotionally about who he
is and who he's become and what he's had
to do since he's become a superhero and
then just to watch that play out in one
division it's extraordinary and jaclyn's
right it was one of the bigger twists
that we got in that very first show and
so one division for you because again
this is the first one so watching wanda
vision before any of these other ones
came along what was your thought at the
time about what the mcu tv shows are
doing and setting up for the future well
i thought one division
i mean looking back now
things have just not been the same since
one division the one division experience
was something that just hasn't been
replicated no show has come close to
that and that's not to say that other
shows just aren't good it's just to say
that the one division experience was
something else you know i thought
stylistically this was such a switch up
from everything that the mcu had done in
phases one two and three having the show
be a sitcom the way it was structure the
way it was structured the acting
performances from elizabeth olsen and
paul bettany was a massive standout and
i don't think a disney plush show has
elevated a character the way one
division elevated wanda prior to wanda
mission wanda was a badass in age of
ultron civil war infinity war end game
but after one division
that was like the birth of that was the
birth of the wanda stance and when one
want when wanda was shown in the trailer
for multiverse of madness in theaters
with spider-man knowing home there's a
reason everyone in the theater went
crazy when they saw wanda because it was
one
and it was because it was because of one
division one division completely just
just elevated that character to a whole
other level while also introducing those
sitcom vibes and i thought it was
written pr very well monica rambo was a
great part of the series as well for me
personally she's one of my fav favorite
new phase four characters that are now
like introduced in the mcu jimmy wu come
on now who are we and we also get to see
just how much wanda cares about
preserving this version of herself and
then obviously we see the negative
effects that can have with multiverse of
madness and so yeah we're going to talk
about doctor strange too now folks too
so buckle up because this was sort of
the litmus test is can you have a
character that we know from the movies
now lead a show that is very
different and very not your conventional
tv show and then can we take what
happened in that show and put it back
into movies and i think that from that
standpoint i think that the experiment
did work i wasn't the biggest multiverse
of madness fan by any stretch of the
imagination but
seeing that a character can go through
that arc on the small screen and then
have us all just kind of being able to
have that information walking it to the
big screen jaclyn does that do more for
the mcu for you that we can have these
stories told and then we can put it back
onto the big screen or does it just make
you feel how i feel sometimes where it's
like now you're just giving me so much
homework before every one of these
movies comes out that it's just more
work for me i mean i think yes and no i
think it just depends on how immersive
of an ncu fan you want to be the one
thing i will say for anyone's like oh um
well i feel like i need to like watch no
you don't there's youtube you can watch
one ten minute video and you will know
what you need to do like that is the
joke of jokes i'm like y'all like
watching the whole series you're
watching a youtube video people like
matt have made an entire industry about
getting you caught up before you go see
a movie you should see our conversations
when we get to see each other in the red
carpet going into one of these things i
just talked to matt for like fine i'm
like hey man you just what's the prep
for this one yeah just help me out a
little bit trust me you have someone in
your life that can get you deed up so
that's not really an issue however i do
think when you think about this it's
sort of like a long-running book series
like we're now getting into like the
alphabet series where
they have to be careful how
self-referential they want to be
and i do think this next phase you're
going to see a lot more folks come on
the scene that look more like the
introduction of everyone after captain
america where there may be slight easter
eggs
to
what part of this universe they are in
and other things that have happened
within it but it does not mean that it
is going to be as contingent they kind
of have to make this first part very
contingent so they can expand later
because think about it this way at the
beginning of say
black panther when you meet ulysses claw
and he talks i'm sorry in the middle of
a age of ultron when you meet ulysses
claw and it sort of sets up black
panther you just get introduced to that
guy and there's little easter eggs as to
what he's going to be and how he's going
to be but you don't know anything else
now looking back on it it looks like
this grand sweeping plan so i think
they're going to be less backwards
referential and more forwards
referential and then it will
be a little bit better because i do
think
keeping them so incestuous like this is
gonna be problematic going forward all
right so as we look forward to more mcu
streaming shows like we said miss marvel
currently
going through its run
supes and then we have she-hulk coming
out we have a few more shows that have
been announced so as we look to the
future of the landscape here with the
streaming shows is there one that you're
like that's the one that i got by that's
that's the one that's going to take this
to the next level that could be my new
favorite show
of all of them
yeah i mean i think matt has his answer
better but i will tell you this
i loved
everything in the netflix daredevil
shows save anything that involved iron
fist yeah i'm going to be basic that way
everybody had issues with iron fist but
whatever
uh it is what it is
i think
i'm gonna be interested to see what they
do with those characters and how they do
those characters forward i'm not saying
that is going to be the greatest show
ever but i guarantee you if they mess it
up they will they will create a villain
in me
like that will be my villain origin
story if they mess up the brilliance of
jessica james is one of my favorite
favorite favorite mcu shows it was so
smartly written daredevil luke cage like
no jacqueline i 100 agree with you like
like you cannot
bring back these characters from such a
beloved show arguably you know it's
talked about as one of the greatest
superhero shows of all time yes i don't
think you can bring back
vincent d'onofrious kingpin charlie cox
as matt murdock for
a show that just
is watered down and just doesn't do
these characters justice i feel like a
lot of fans will be disappointed with
that so yeah i mean i'm right with there
with you like daredev the daredevil
marvel disney plus series is definitely
my most anticipated upcoming disney
plush show
because you have all of those different
characters coming back and i love matt
murdock and i love charlie cox and
vincent d'onofrio and i think that's the
theory i'll have it really quick not to
cut you off soups is that the fear that
you all have something maybe from
hawkeye is is that you don't want that
version of kingpin in the
in whatever the the disney version of
your you know luke cage and your jessica
jones and your daredevils are yeah i
mean i do think they're softly rebooting
the characters to kind of like disney fy
them because i don't think disney's
gonna have vincent d'onofrio smashing
guys
in like the the corner of a truck the
truck door see i disagree
i don't think they're i think i don't
think they're gonna go that dark i mean
for moon knight they were saying like
we're not holding back you know
this is going us like i think moon
knight was as dark as they're probably
willing to go and i think it's going to
be the same thing with the daredevil
series
i hope i'm wrong but i think you're
wrong because of the [ __ ] position
the reason why i say that the fox
acquisition already changed disney plus
it already changed disney uh
significantly because they can no longer
sort of cordon off their
non-family-friendly entertainment and be
be a global brand disney realized very
quickly if they keep marketing
themselves as the kids channel
they are not going to be able to reach
the global audience they want to receive
on disney plus and if you look at disney
plus and what it has they have national
geographic they have a lot of stuff
and they have all the fox old catalogs
including hugh jackman's butt and
wolverine they have all of the stuff
from those netflix shows is go is
already on disney plus right now
so
i actually think they're using these
series as a way to gateway folks into
this more adult content because i think
they know they need to grow up and this
is one of the few series that if they go
dark in them people aren't going to
think of is it a left turn they're just
gonna be like oh this is just them
continuing this path and so then when
they do it with another property later
it's gonna be like well this was already
the path that they're on with big
companies like this they cannot make
it's moving the titanic you can't make
sharp turns you have to do it in little
degrees
little little turns until eventually
you're turning right and nobody paid
attention and when you're disney those
turns honestly have to be microscopic
but if you watch them you can see and so
i actually think they're gonna get there
i hope all the disney executives just
heard exactly what you said i mean i
think they know that we want i mean they
know that already dude again they're
smarter people than me that put that
into the game plan before they acquired
fox so like this is just what's
interesting with the internet is y'all
like the internet in general and i
include me i shouldn't say y'all we want
it now companies don't work that way it
takes 50 meetings just to plan lunch
like y'all need to understand that like
organization and like
moving quickly is actually bad for
business and why does it take 50
meetings to plan for lunch because all
you all are on slack making gifts and
trying to make each other laugh instead
of getting actual work done i contend to
this day slack is actually bad for
business different conversation i love
that you pointed out nat geo being
available on disney plus because if you
all think that kingpin squishing a guy's
head is is too much for the kids go put
on that geo
it's nothing but lion genitalia all day
long lions don't look like they do in
lion king you're just seeing full-on
male lion stuff hanging out when you
watch nat geo so if you can't handle
that you definitely can't handle
whatever kingpin is going to be bringing
to the table i am i the only one because
i know that there was like a big stink
about oh i don't know about the tone of
this show when the effects don't look
finished i can't stand that argument
when you see a trailer on your phone but
she-hulk i really like the tone of that
show am i the only one am i on she-hulk
i went by myself i think that's going to
be a lot of fun and i can't wait to see
that i'm a little bit skeptical on that
one i just
first of all every creative decision
they've made about this show besides the
casting of tatiana
uh
has been questionable i really question
the creative team around this one and i
don't mean to be misogynistic around it
it's not the first female show runner
we've had in this universe we've had
falcon of the winter soldier had a
female director you know like it's not
that case
but that show just seems to have some
inherent issues with the understanding
of what she hold the character is going
to mean based on what i have seen so
i i'm okay to be surprised but if
there's one that i'm looking out for to
be like this is probably not gonna work
i am absolutely circling that one with a
big bullseye okay matt break the tie do
we have some anticipation or more
apprehension for she-hulk yeah i'm
excited for shihoka and one of the
reasons i'm really excited for shihoku
is that it's finally breaking the six
episode model that we've been going
through since one division i'm pretty
sure every fan on this earth has said
that we want more than six episodes from
these shows and shiok is gonna have nine
episodes and i love the i just loved all
the vibes that first trailer gave us the
cgi again they still have a couple of
months to tidy up on that cgi i hope it
i hope it improves but uh
yeah i just i love the vibe that that
trailer gave us so i'm super excited for
shio kami i'm excited that we're gonna
have nine episodes to really dive deep
into this character to see her go on all
these different adventures to you know
this was a series that kevin feige teed
up will have like because she's a lawyer
for superheroes there's a chance that we
could see other familiar faces so i
think there's a lot to be excited about
we also got professor hulk tim roth has
the abomination wong is going to be in
this
i'm excited i just want to see what it's
like to be she-hulk on the dating scene
in a big city because we got hints of
that with the trailer and that's really
what i want to focus on it's going to be
fun having ruffalo in there her cousin
pop in teaching her how you know it
ain't easy being green but i just kind
of want to see what it's like for
somebody who has that that ability where
if your heart great gets too up you know
stuff happens i i kind of am excited to
see how that factors into the world and
that is exactly what i don't like about
this because the she-hulk character from
the comics like it's not like dating
wasn't an aspect of her rage monster but
they're already just centering it in
such a like
weird woman way again i'm just gonna go
ahead and tell y'all i do not think this
this show is gonna play well that is my
it seems like it's a show
that was written by women made for what
they think men want and i'm just
very
thinking that is not going to work just
let me put that out there i see where
you're i see where i'm like i just
i don't think this is gonna work maybe
i'm judging the material and it's not
based on the things that normal people
are wishing about like the acting i
think is gonna be great i think that the
cgi will definitely get worked out i
think there are some fundamental issues
with the creative decisions around how
they are presenting the character of
she-hulk who had a very different vibe
in the comics that i read than this like
just the fact that romance is such a
central part of who she is she is more
like matt murdock
way more like matt murdock and there's a
darkness to this that's not the biggest
romantic i've ever yeah like it seems
like they wanted to make like imagine a
comic book character that you read more
like matt murdock and they turning her
into bridget jones on scene yeah i don't
want this thing to be sex in the city
you know featuring
seems to be kind of what they're writing
i just kind of like that we get to
experience the more mundane aspects of a
superhero's life where it isn't all just
work saving the world you know how do
you just do your day-to-day there's a
great commercial and i can't remember
what it was even for but it might have
been like a geico but it just shows this
like superhero-ish kind of character
that looks kind of like a spider-man or
a kick-ass and in between fighting crime
just a dude in his one bedroom apartment
heating up a microwave meal and that's
like it it's like your life is so boring
when you're not saving the world so what
else do you do to fill the time you know
that's that sort of thing well we we've
actually done a pretty good job of
filling this hour in uh talking about
mcu shows and streaming shows so i'll
give the final word here to uh to matt
supes matt ramos um just about
mcu in general when it comes to
television we talked about you're most
looking forward to what they do with
daredevil but there's a lot of other
exciting stuff on the horizon if i'm
just a regular person on the street and
i'm one of your fans i come up to you
and i say hey i love the movies why do i
need to check out these shows what would
just be your sort of blanket statement
that you would say to them my blanket
statement to them is that this is still
very much a part of the mcu you know to
not go into multiverse of madness having
not watched one division you're gonna be
lost and with a lot of these newer
disney plush shows introducing new
characters like kamala khan we're going
to meet her we're we're not going to
meet her we're going to see her in the
marvels getting that back story and
learning to i guess dive deep and
growing to love these characters in
their own series
is going to add to your experience when
you see them again on the big screen it
was just announced a week ago that we're
getting a thunderbolts movie and there's
rumors that we're going to see john
walker bucky in that so having seen the
falcon and the winter soldier i'm
infinitely more excited to see those
characters again in that movie so i
would say that the the disney plush
shows are are very important in keeping
us busy until we get to those big events
like you guys said once we get back in
theaters to witness another great marvel
movie set by a a great fan and who's
cultivated a great career out of the
world of entertainment and hosting and
particularly talking about fun stuff
like the world of comic books and how
they're adapted into film and television
or you can be like jaclyn and sometimes
me and you can just watch the youtube
recap for 10 minutes and then head on
into multiverse of madness or thor 11
thunder whatever the next big movie is
too that's also a fair way to go but i i
think that you'll be rewarded the more
you investigate into these shows even
though i have my bones to pick with the
mcu the multiverse i should say in time
bending yeah it's still pretty fun to
see loki is an alligator so uh that is
gonna do it for our tv talk today let's
transition right on over to mailbag hit
the music brian
catch up crew member donald rogers today
chiming in y'all can be like donald
rogers and email us anytime rt is wrong
at
rottentomatoes.com tell us how you're
feeling about our particular movie or
show and what you want us to discuss
about it donald rogers says dear
jacqueline mark producee lucy tim brian
an esteemed guest matt soups in this
case first thank you for reading my
email recommending closer closer i
should say the julia roberts clive owen
pick i am writing once again to
recommend another movie ty west's ex
i hate it period
let's talk pros because i'm polite the
cinematography was cool i guess and the
kills were mostly lol and i sincerely
appreciated the mostly nude dad bod okay
wow that movie was an aegis af maybe i
don't know film i just learned about
exploitation and maybe i'm sensitive in
my gay old age of 36 but like has ty
west spent time with the elderly did ty
west really think some viewers would buy
that an elderly woman would go on a
killing because she can't netflix and
chill i'm just very confused at how this
movie is certified fresh at 95 percent
it was 97 when i saw it at the time of
his premiere jacqueline and mark my
therapist says my feelings are valid but
please validate my feelings about this
movie much love donald jacqueline you uh
you are you pro recon x
i have seen taiwan's ex i don't hate it
but i do know that there is vitriol
against it
and i do want to validate your feelings
and the one thing i would tell you is
all movies about feelings all feelings
about movies are valid sir that's why we
have this podcast so let me add to that
with your therapist also keep writing us
letters donald you're fabulous we do
love donald and uh thank you for
recommending uh closer by the way too
that's a movie we got to get on this
show sooner rather than later it was
great i still can't believe we haven't
had soups on the show before uh matt
ramos is uh
by day soups by night on the interwebs
it's been an absolute joy seeing you and
chatting with you once again about this
stuff where is like your central hub
that you want to refer everybody to is
listening who's watching this show they
want to check more soup stuff out where
should they go so guys i am all over
social media soups on youtube soups on
tick tock the real soups on twitter the
real soup's on instagram we're still
working out that username situation but
again if you guys want to keep up with
everything up to if you guys want to
stay up to date with everything going on
in the world of pop culture make sure to
check your boy out and
we'll have some fun
so it's soups and then occasionally you
just gotta distinguish the fact that you
are in fact the real soups because
there's a lot of imposters out there on
twitter that is at the real soups on
twitter uh like i said you can email us
anytime for those videos and for mailbag
rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com
subscribe rate review all that good
stuff jacqueline comic con is right
around the corner and i do have my
annual stand up show at american comedy
company down there you can get tickets
at mark ellis dot live me a lot of
special guests telling jokes so it's
going to be a good time right in the
gaslamp district do you are you doing
the comic con this year if somebody
hires me but i don't think we're
covering it for rotten tomatoes so i'm
actually gonna enjoy not getting on a
sweaty train with a bunch of
entertainment journalists you're gonna
miss me
i will miss you but you're gonna miss
hanging out i am positive i'm not going
to comic con which means i'll probably
be going to comic con because somebody's
going to call me and be like oh hey we
want you to come down for this thing or
whatever like rotten tomatoes would be
like last minute actually just kidding
we're going to go so if i am i will be
there sir i i'll tell you what i'll do
i'll book a suite that way you have a
sofa couch to sleep on just in case you
want to last minute
well that is going to do it for us here
today on rotten tomatoes is wrong for
our special guest matt soups that's matt
ramos jacqueline coley my esteemed
co-host brian perez producer lucy tim
ryan the whole crew behind the scenes
here at rotten tomatoes i am merely mark
ellis saying thank you good night good
luck and
just stop bending time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you